[Music]  [Applause]  roland  the bridge is collapsing i'm gonna fall  oh no  is that the man in black roland you have  followed my trail successfully  but only one of you will meet me on the  other side  you must make a choice jake or the dark  tower the tower  you don't need a minute to think about  it or roland please help me  okay kid are you going to show me the  tower  oh my god i was not expecting that  i'm sure i could bring him back if i  need to there will be water  if god wills it you seem pretty  confident about that it's car  it's was murdering him car was that car  rolling murder is murder car rolling you  seem a little upset  i'm just a little surprised okay i'm not  the nicest person but  uh that was that was a lot and that was  a lot roland i'm sure he'll get over it  i'm  kind of like a father figure to him you  a father figure  what kind of sick man would write such a  thing  [Music]  you